en france le problème de ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler les gens du voyage
essentiellement des familles venues de
roumanie ou de l'ex yougoslavie gitans
roms empoisonne de plus en plus souvent
la vie des mères et de l'administration
des petites comme des grandes localités
à lesquin dans nord dans l'agglomération
lilloise le préfet a décidé de faire
évacuer un campement qu'ils jugeaient
dangereux et insalubres pour installer
ces gens du voyage ailleurs et leur
offrir un minimum de confort en
attendant une éventuelle régularisation
frédéric vion dominique maes hier pour
la première fois depuis longtemps il
retrouvait des conditions de vie
décentes
par habitude on les appelait les gitans
de l'autoroute en tout plus de 120
personnes en majorité des roms venus du
monténégro et que la préfecture du nord
reloger tiers dans cet hôtel de la
banlieue lilloise
jusque là les 20 familles vivaient ici
sur ce terre-plein entre deux autoroutes
certains ont vécu plus d'une année dans
des conditions de vie totalement
insalubres sans eau ni chauffage ni
toilettes ni électricité
autant dire que l'hôtel qu'on leur
propose l'heure semble un palace
aujourd'hui si c'est mieux pour se laver
pour dormir mais l'hôtel n'était qu'une
solution provisoire pour une nuit
seulement le temps d'emménager railleur
est cette fois plus durablement sur la
zone de l'aéroport de lille la
préfecture a installé un autre campement
un vrai celui-là
ici les enfants découvrent le confort un
confort dont ils n'ont vraiment pas
l'habitude une petite fille que j'ai pu
rencontrer sa première préoccupation
s'était demandé si je pouvais lui donner
une robe propre parce qu'elle en avait
pas en attendant le résultat de leur
demande d'asile
les réfugiés sont condamnés à vivre de
la charité en effet comme à tous les
demandeurs d'asile territoriales la
france ne leur accordent ni argent ni le
droit de chercher un travail